because the last time you guys were on
the show together and Anthony and Greg
they did a boxing challenge and in a bit
of a shock result Anthony won
heavyweight champion of would beat so
this time this time we've got another
challenge with the last time it was you
know those boxing things you hit the box
in there so that we did the last time
this time we've gone for one of those
funfair a test of strength machines okay
so if you'd like to bring in the machine
here it is
[Music]
come down to our message thread now the
two of you gotta send one you're gonna
have a bit of a faceoff in front of it
okay okay we're taking this seriously
yeah we're taking it seriously and it's
not it's it is of strength with I
believe technique plays a huge part in
knots all right so Ken Brown is going to
give us a little bit of form before we
do this if you do your face off - your
face off come on come on okay off you go
[Music]
[Applause]
disputed heavyweight champion of the
world
right they call him I see looking at
then call him Korea the Korea because he
sometimes delivers unless he gets stuck
in traffic
it is Greg
[Applause]
you know first let's have you I thought
that was gonna be heavier okay
okay you go first you mind the cameras
here we go
so golf Oh
[Applause]
well you might miss it as well
Oh God
I've seen you do a thing and I like your
own suit but can you do the deadlift
thing space
[Applause]
okay don't don't now slam me on my yes
so the takeoffs we're gonna set you down
Jay thank you thank you let me tell you
something God will be so gentle for
Jamie before it's done so what sort of a
spatial expression should you go for
feature ever it feels natural just yet
important thing is don't get blown up
put your brave yes you know you can't
look terrified and I you're frightened
but you're still brave yes frightened
brave what's the countdown is it 3 2 1
go okay so you're going on 1 on 3
do it okay okay so it's three
[Applause]
let's let's see it lets see it Jamie
he's running he's running
[Applause]
you won't make your kids really jealous
that is if you just posed with a
lightsaber with thin that would actually
make them very Jeff do it do it I've got
one I've got one in Manchester United at
red you know I really do I really don't
where's the blue one again okay there's
the blue one and actually and here's the
thing because you're in is that you're
in the new King Arthur film I am just a
small part yeah have you done some sort
training can we not kill Kylie there's a
so basically to turn this on you push
you push that thing that one up okay
you've met your match
I just wanted to meet you
we've got a tandem bike so if you bring
in the the green screen you will put you
on the streets of Paris okay if you go
over to the bike okay do and I think for
once James should be at the back there
you go there is a theme in matter you're
never at the back in the pan are okay
we've talked about this last time I know
hang on where's this why's my god oh
because you put the Stars
with the scarves are going fast right
you see you won the Stars round
oh there you go lovely lovely okay okay
so so can we have a romantic background
now please mr. antic okay and I'll be
cycling pretend to be sorry don't
actually cycle that was a think okay I
want you to think up which you star in
the playback was it looked like Jamie
did a really big far
[Laughter]
okay here goes Maddy here goes back to
it okay so
[Applause]
[Applause]
one more let's get someone a digit you'd
like to do it oh you'd be so good at it
you're okay you're fixed your fist okay
you'll fit right now your fist at the
moment you're okay okay okay you've seen
the others you've seen the others I
think the important thing is
particularly because you look so
beautiful
big face at the end okay so we're
looking for high chair even forward okay
okay yeah you're good okay okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I hear she may not be Mission Impossible
7
[Music]
you